PTS provides simple abstractions, namely channel
and simple perimeters to manipulate these abstractions,
namely get and put. And these channels
can be anywhere in the distributed system,
just like UNIX sockets, these are named
entitities. That are network-wide unique and therefore,
you can have a large scale distributed
computation in which handles exist everywhere and
you can discover them and connect to them and do I/O on them using get and put.
All the heavy lifting that is the systems work that needs to happen. In order
to support this channel abstraction and the operations
that you do want channel abstractions like the
get and put operations, are all managed under
the cover by the the run time system
of pts. So PTS channels can be anywhere, just like unix sockets,
can be accessed from anywhere, and they are network wide unqiue, and this is
a similarity of the channels to unix sockets, in terms of the ubiquity,in
the entire distributive system. But what
makes PTS channels particularly attractive for situation
awareness applications is that the run time system and the APIs,
provided for manipulating the channel Treats time as a first class
entity. What we mean by that is time is manipulatable by
the application, in the way it specifies items to the runtime
system. And it queries the runtime system using time as
index into the channel, and that's what is unique about the PTS channels.
The second unique property of the PTS extraction is that, it allows streams
to be persistent under application control.
Remember that these sensors are producing data
24/7. Therefore continuously data is being
produced, and all of it cannot obviously
be held in the memory of the CPU, so they have to be persisted
on more archival storage like a disc, and PTS
provides the ability to persist the streams under application control.
The flip side of persisting streams is that when a query
comes in. For a particular channel, it is actually
saying get me items from a lower bound to an upper bound, and the lower bound
may be yesterday, which means that we are asking for data that are historical in
nature in addition to live data. So the PTS run time system and the semantics
of channels, allows seamlessly handling live and historical
data. The perimeters are just get and put,
whether we are accessing data that is current or
historical. You give a lower bone marker and an upper
bone marker and the run time system gets to
work in doing whatever heavy lifting that needs to be
done. To bring the data that you're looking for
between the lower bond marker and the upper bond marker.
So that's the power of the PTS channel perimeter.
It is simple to use, but at the same time
it provides handles that will make the life of the domain expert that is
developing. A situation awareness application, so much
easier because it allows time to be
manipulated as a first class entity recognized
by the programming system. And it allows
persistence for data beyond the lifetime of
a computation by moving it to archive
storage under application control. And thirdly, it
allows for seamlessly integrating live and historical data.